é a gente está vendo aqui na no evento
uma série de iniciativas que deram muito
certo é aqui no amazonas e recentemente
na verdade já que recentemente se
concretizou mais uma delas é e que eu
fiz é parte desse desse projeto é a mais
ou menos cinco anos atrás um grupo de de
alunos é da universidade federal do
amazonas se juntou com alguns
professores é e montar uma empresa de
tecnologia principalmente voltado ao
desenvolvimento de tecnologias e
produtos para o varejo mais focada no
varejo online é no início do projeto era
basicamente a construção ali de um
sistema de comparador de preços era
muito parecido com empresas como buscapé
acho que são mais conhecidos hoje em dia
é essa só que essa essa semente ali que
começou é a cinco anos atrás dele com
esse grupo chegou a ter uma relevância
muito maior
depois de alguns anos onde a empresa
acabou se tornando líder no
desenvolvimento de tecnologias para e
commerce e chamou a atenção de uma série
de outras empresas e e essa aí é essa
e essa tensão digamos assim que a
empresa acabou tendo combinou digamos
assim é chegou num ponto em que foi
feita uma proposta de aquisição é por um
grande varejista chama links então a
linx adquiriu animou numa negociação num
evento de extrema relevância é para o
mercado de tecnologia nacional é e
condições muito grandes é de tornar essa
empresa muito relevante não só no brasil
mas até no exterior
mas assim é essa essa essa história é
essa a gente poderia bem possível passar
muito tempo falando sobre essa parte
mais é mais do negócio da
da thá da empresa mas tem uma história
um pouco mais é anterior é que precede
toda essa história do sucesso da mimo é
que começou em 2004 quando um grupo de
alunos começou a graduação em ciência da
computação é ea gente tinha começado a
estudar um departamento que estava
começando a se estruturar começando a a
a ganhar é corpo é e com objetivos bem
bem ousadas
é por exemplo como eu já tinha começado
o processo o processo para criar um
mestrado na área de ciência da
computação e posteriormente já tinha o
objetivo de criar da criação do programa
de doutorado e tinha muita ambição desse
grupo é isso torna referência em
pesquisa em algumas áreas principalmente
em áreas relacionadas à recuperação de
informação machine learning é
inteligência artificial informática na
educação entre outras coisas e como era
um grupo era um departamento
relativamente jovem
é preciso que essa essa existe uma e que
existisse uma parceria muito forte entre
os professores desse departamento
os alunos que estavam lá é isso gerou
uma série de de benefícios futuros não
só resultando em iniciativas como a nemo
com uma empresa que foi fundada depois
mas com o fortalecimento do departamento
com o crescimento deste departamento e
com outras iniciativas que deram muito
certo
durante esse processo de graduação é
essa parceria essas parcerias entre
professores e alunos se como cada vez
mais forte é principalmente pela pela
pelo envolvimento desse grupo em
projetos de pesquisas é através de bikes
boa bolsa de pesquisa serão comentadas é
tanto por instituições federais como
daqui do amazonas
algumas algumas projetos de pesquisa
envolvendo empresas em projetos de
extensão é participação em congressos
ah ah a participação também o convívio
com pessoas com pesquisadores de outras
universidades é e principalmente em
alguns casos os projetos com empresas é
por exemplo para citar algumas têm
alguns projectos relacionados com com o
pé e algumas outras iniciativas que
acabaram aproximando esse grupo é e e
dando esse grupo um olhar um pouco
diferente do que se pode fazer com a
pesquisa que a gente estava
desenvolvendo
quando esse grupo chegou no mestrado já
tinha 11 uma visão um pouco diferente do
que a gente queria fazer no futuro
inicialmente é a cabeça era muito na
linha de fazer mestrado depois do apito
dourado e eventualmente todos se
tornaram professores ou trabalharia o
instituto de pesquisa é mas já existe um
desejo desse grupo que desde a graduação
é trabalhar muito próximo dos
professores é de colocar todo aquele
conhecimento de pesquisa todo aquele é
aquele conjunto de de conhecimento que
tinha sido adquirido nesse período é
colocar esse conhecimento na prática é e
como a gente já tinha visto e já tinha
participado de alguns projetos é
próximos assim de empresas
a gente já fez durante o período de
mestrado já começou é já tinha lhe
alguns índices de acidentes desse grupo
de querer colocar esse conhecimento em
prática e quem sabe até é criar uma
empresa o eventualmente criar um negócio
maior do que simplesmente é terminar a
graduação terminar o mestrado e e acabar
seguindo uma vida com uma carreira
profissional o mais padrão os em 2008
pelo menos no meio que a gente estava
inserido nos falava muito ainda de
startup criação de empresas
hoje hoje isso é muito mais disseminado
e as pessoas
você vai na universidade ou se conversa
com outras pessoas que já terminaram
principalmente na área de tecnologia
saíram da faculdade
se fala muito assim
a criação de empresas na época a gente
tinha pouco essa visão pelo menos no no
cenário em que a gente estava até existe
uma certa cultura do tipo aluno bolsista
se preocupa simplesmente estudar e o
professor dá aula então essa relação
acaba ali isso e existe um certo receio
de compartilhar essa vontade de
eventualmente por exemplo abrir uma
empresa é abrir uma uma startup enfim
colocar uma idéia na prática e isso
disso poder virar um negócio depende a
gente durante esse período de de
mestrado
a gente estava com uma uma certa vontade
de fazer algumas coisas e começou ali
entre grupo de amigos a desenvolver
alguns projetos mas com extremo receio é
de que nossos orientadores por exemplo
soubessem disso porque tinha essa
questão se você sonha tinha síntese
receio de sessão bolsista se estudem
professores fazem ali seu trabalho de
orientação e acabou mas uma digamos
assim uma tentativa de até a gente se
preservar contou com alguns professores
um projeto que a gente está trabalhando
fora lhe do foco do da pós graduação mas
com certo receio ali de de repente ser
penalizado de do professor chegar e
brigar com a gente enfim a gente pra
evitar também que ele sabe que está
fazendo alguma coisa por outros meios
e pra cá pra nossa digamos assim
surpresa quando a gente encontra se pode
trabalhar num projecto aqui é isso foi
muito bem recebido assim é tão bem
recebido que em vez de ter uma posição
do tipo pare de fazer isso é bom estudar
vão cuidar só do seu mestrado da sua
dissertação eles chamada gente pra
chamar a gente pra digamos assim é pegar
tudo que vocês fizeram vamos juntar as
experiências que a gente já tem
experiências de pesquisa desenvolvimento
um negócio e vamos tentar criar algo
mais relevante foi aí que se decidiu
assim
esse grupo de professores da lucira
vamos criar uma empresa de tecnologia a
gente tem uma bagagem boa é de pesquisa
tem uma bagagem boa de de de qualidade
da dos profissionais que estavam ali
tinham conhecimento já um pouco de
gestão da parte de de negócios ea gente
é decidiu seguir esse caminho é isso
depois de um tempo resultou numa empresa
que teve sucesso assim teve é chegou
chegou a alcançar relevância que quer
mesmo tomou no caso
mas independente disso foi uma
experiência que trouxe crescimento
profissional abre oportunidades com uma
série de pessoas não só para a gente é
mas a empresa chegou a ter mais de 50
funcionários é formou muita gente é e
assim mais do que mais do que ter
sucesso não empresa todo todo o processo
que a gente passou foi muito rico foi
muito é foi muito bom ajudou muita gente
é ea gente acabou criando uma empresa é
que teve que teve muita relevância no
cenário tecnologia nacional e era uma
empresa amazonense onde assim a gente
sabe que não é tão comum e ainda ainda
surgirem muitas empresas dessa área é
muito mais concentrada no no sudeste do
país no sul e sudeste
enfim no fundo mais do que a questão do
do sucesso entrar na empresa da demo
dessa relevância que a empresa tomou no
cenário nacional é que essa essa
parceria entre os professores e alunos
que era muito ali é pouco incentivada
pode trazer resultados muito bons não só
para as pessoas envolvidas mas pra
comunidade pro pra lá no caso aqui da
cidade acabou formando e empregando
muita gente e eu acho que essa é uma
prática que precisa ser mais
incentivados seja em universidades
públicas e privadas escolas e até
empresas empresas
é até estranho falar no conceito de
processos
quando empresa mas no caso da daemo
ficou muito que existe uma relação muito
boa entre é alguns funcionários que
tinham conhecimento digamos assim mais
elevado como é pessoas que tinham
mestrado doutorado com algum funcionário
que estão entrando essas parcerias
internas acabaram gerando áreas de
produtos áreas de negócio que depois
tiveram muita relevância da empresa
enfim é uma parceria que se mostra te já
trouxe muitos outros bons resultados
antes
é uma experiência que parte do grupo de
professores que fizeram parte dessa da
neemo já tinham tido uma experiência
anterior na universidade federal de
minas gerais onde eles fundaram junto
com outros professores
a empresa chamada com 1 em 2000 é a
cunhã acabou sendo vendida em 2005 pelo
google é e foi a porta de entrada para o
google aqui no brasil então essa
parceria
assim como na mesmo assim como aqui no
amazonas é traz apps incentivar da
maneira correta se executar da maneira
certa pode trazer muitos ganhos não só
para as pessoas que estão envolvidas
nesse projeto mas para toda a comunidade
onde esses essas iniciativas estão
inseridas
obrigado